well the black box as I said has been
found never standing by for us um that
will obviously have more clues for us
Neville what do we know so far about
what tragically happened yesterday
well now questions are being raised
about about the crash because yesterday
when it when the plane crashed the
weather was quite clear it was the Sun
was shining there was no fog or or any
sort of winter effects on on bokra at
that point of time there are questions
also being raised why the poker
International Airport was pushed by the
government to to open uh its airstrip
also why the pilot had requested to land
from a different runaway rather from the
western side of of the strip rather than
the assigned one to him now Nepal does
have uh doesn't have a very good track
record in terms of air safety or since
2000 over 350 people have died in
aircraft and helicopter crashes across
the country the European Union in 2013
has has put a blanket ban on Netflix
airlines are coming into the airspace of
the union and and we've seen a boom in
the aircraft airline industry in Nepal
uh which many are questioning or
questioning the concerns of a compromise
to safety regulations in the country but
now that the investigations are taking
place the Prime Minister patanda has
given a 45-day deadline to this
five-member group committee to
investigate into the causes we'll have
to wait and see what were the real
causes of this crash